[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your majesties
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
a very warm welcome
to
this european development days
conference
the next 48 hours
will bring together
leaders practitioners
policy makers
and decision makers
and together we will you will
share analysis
you will shape best practices
and you will also map the priorities for
the future
kovit 19 has harshly exposed the impact
of today's
incomplete
incompatible
or disconnected global infrastructure
as we all know the lack of digital
digital connections in many places the
disruption to our supply chains
and the scarcity of medical goods have
all had a tremendous
impact both human and economic
we may not be able to solve all the
world's problems in the coming two days
but we're certainly going going to give
it a try and we're going to start
together working on solving quite a few
of those problems
as you know
the the aim of the global gateway
strategy
is to boost smart
clean and secure links
in the digital energy and transport
sector
the strategy the global gateway also
aims to seek also aims to strengthen
health education and research systems
across the world
in partnership with a global gateway
the eu aims to support major investments
that will increase
global connections and address the
monumental problems the world we are all
facing
we have a mountain to climb we have a
mountain ahead of us and a very high one
but according to g20 estimates the
global investment structure
infrastructure
deficit will hit 13 trillion euros by
2040 that is in less than 20 years
and even more money will be needed to
stay on track
to limit the climate change disaster
that is looming
it is of course well known that
transport systems are key contributors
to this
and the global gateway also plans
to promote worldwide infrastructure
investments
that create sustainable smart resilient
inclusive
and safe transport networks an
absolutely essential part of our
infrastructures and that means railroad
ports airports or even border crossings
in many places
so it is indeed quite a challenge quite
a mountain we have ahead of us
and it's one of many
we do have exciting times ahead
not least in this very place in this
very hall in this very studio where many
of you heads of state and government or
head of international organizations have
joined us to deliver keynote speeches
that will outline your vision
for the global gateway
in both international
and domestic contexts
our world is growing our world is moving
the conference today and tomorrow will
build on the achievements
of the 2018 eu asia connectivity
strategy for example the recent
initiatives that involve japan india the
western balkan but it will also build on
other initiatives that involve africa
central asia and
america
so do stand by for some very powerful
keynotes this morning some very powerful
introductory uh speeches but also for
some very intensive debates which are
going to take place in the various
studios throughout the next couple of
days
ladies and gentlemen we can now open
officially the european development days
i understand we have a connection to
president van der leyen now
unfortunately due to her very busy
agenda she could not join us in person
this morning but president van der leyen
are you with us
hello yes indeed yes indeed thank you
good morning president
good morning
good morning and welcome good morning
we're delighted to have you with us we
understand that you have a very busy
agenda we're sorry you could not join us
here in the hall but please the floor is
yours
thank you so much your majesties
excellence is distinguished guests and
ladies and gentlemen indeed it is a
great pleasure to welcome you to the now
15th edition of the european development
days
this is the place where europe meets the
global development community and
partners from all corners of the world
and this year we gather in a delicate
moment the world has been shocked and
shaken by russia's aggression on ukraine
but while the global media's attention
rightly so was focusing mostly on the
war
something else happened below the raider
on the fourth day of russia's aggression
the leading authority on climate change
the ipcc
issued a stark warning to the global
community
they demonstrated that our climate is
changing faster than our capacity to
adapt to it so we must speed up the
investments to cut emissions
or face dramatic consequences
the window of opportunity of our action
is still open
but the global investment gap is still
not closing
global infrastructure investment
collapsed in 2020 because of the
pandemic
and it took us almost two years before
it went back to pre-pandemic levels
but then russia attacked ukraine rocking
the global economy once again
and you know it energy prices have
skyrocketed
vulnerable countries across the globe
are on the brink of a massive food
crisis
and at a time when the global economy is
longing for stability to recover and
transform
investors are facing growing uncertainty
the world needs a positive investment
impulse and it needs it now
and we're talking about investment in
clean energy
in roads and bridges that are flood
proof
or buildings that can withstand extreme
heat waves
but also investment to prepare health
systems for example for the pandemics of
the future
or to adapt farming to drier conditions
investments to equip our workers with
skills that match the jobs of tomorrow
or for example investment in digital
infrastructure
because we all know the fuel of the new
economy
is data
so
the fate of future generations depends
more than ever before
on the quality
and quantity
of our infrastructure investment today
and this is where our european strategy
global gateway comes into play
global gateway as you know is europe's
offer to the world that needs massive
investment it aims at mobilizing 300
billion euros by 2027.
150 billion euros of them in africa
so it has the size to make a difference
and just as importantly it lays out a
new approach to big infrastructure
projects
you know very well that for many
countries around the world investments
options
are not only limited
but they all come with a lot of small
print and a very high price sometimes
sometimes it's the environment that pays
the price
sometimes it's workers who are stripped
of their rights
and sometimes it's national sovereignty
that is compromised
well no country should be faced with
such a situation
in which the only option to finance is
essential infra it's essential
infrastructure is to sell out its future
global gateway is about giving countries
a choice
and a better choice
global gateway's investments will be
sustainable both for the environment and
for our partners finances
our investments will always put people
first
and for this we will always co-design
projects
with our partners they have to own the
project so we make sure to deliver
lasting benefits for local communities
and europe has a clear strategic
interest in this
we have an interest in working together
for our common planet it's in our common
interest
we have an interest in making our
neighbors and partners more resilient to
all sort of shocks
we have an interest in replacing
unsustainable dependencies with more
balanced interdependencies
and since we launched global gateway
just over six months ago
the demand for transparent and
value-based investment program has only
grown stronger
now these european development days will
showcase the road we have traveled so
far
but today i would like to focus first
and foremost on the direction of our
travel
three goals
that we can achieve together thanks to
global gateway
and that are key to our sustainable
development are in the focus
the first one is resilience
the second and it's no ranking it's all
at the same level
is sustainability
and the third is cooperation with
neighbors and with like-minded partners
so let me start with resilience
the last few months have shed a light on
some of the great imbalances of the
global economy
take for example vaccines
in pandemic times europe has been the
pharmacy of the world
for every dose of vaccine distributed
inside europe
one dose was shipped abroad
we are by far the world's largest
exporter of vaccines we stayed open when
others decided to keep their production
for themselves
yet
this situation is not sustainable
a continent like africa imports 99 of
the vaccines it needs 99
so we agree with the african union that
this must change
and here global gateway comes into play
in the coming months
we're building together with our african
partners two factories in rwanda and
senegal
to manufacture mrna vaccines
the technology is there
so starting next year the vaccines will
be sold at non-for-profit prices
to african countries
and this will be made in africa for
africa with world class technology
similar work is also ongoing with ghana
and south africa
so the model we have developed with our
partners is incredibly promising
not only for africa
so right here at the european
development days we will launch a
similar initiative with latin america
and the caribbean
this continent has also an immense
potential with highly skilled
researchers
and a growing manufacturing capacity
yet here also the figures it still
imports 10 times more pharmaceutical
products than it exports
with global gateway
we can make our partners stronger and
more resilient
because your strength
is our strength too
another good example is food security
only 50 years ago
africa produced all the food it needed
then conflict and climate change have
made the continent heavily dependent on
food imports and today
a food crisis looms
triggered by russia's deliberate attack
on ukraine's food experts
russian troops are blockading ships full
of wheat crops and cooking oil in
ukrainian ports
russia is deliberately bombarding grain
warehouses in ukraine
and in some cases they are even stealing
ukrainian wheat
this is the reason for the current food
crisis
and to put the record very straight
our sanctions do not touch basic food
commodities and fertilizers
and they are carefully designed not to
affect who trade between russia and
third countries
so right now we are working hard
together with ukraine
to get more grain out of ukraine to
global markets
and to help the most vulnerable
countries
face the emergency
but we must also step up every
continent's own production capacity and
resilience that's the principle
this was at the heart of my visit to
egypt just a few days ago
and we know how to do it
there's a wonderful example the great
green wall has already retaken millions
of hectares of land from the desert
boosting food production from senegal
and niger to ethiopia
now roughly 15
of the project has been completed
and global gateway will put another
brick in the great green wall
as a bulwark
against food insecurity and climate
change
just like we are for example doing in
zambia to strengthen its agricultural
sector
and beyond this we have just proposed to
mobilize an additional 600 million euros
to strengthen local production in
vulnerable countries
on top of the existing package you all
know of 3 billion euros for global food
security
so as with vaccines
the mid and long long-term solution
is local production
and local resilience
and this leads me to the second goal of
global gateway that is sustainability
in a world where resources are limited
and climate change action urgent
all infrastructure investments
must be future proof
you know as well as me that 600 million
africans currently don't have access to
electricity and clean clean energy
that's more than the eu's entire
population
so clean energy from renewables is the
only option
that can both turn the lights on and
preserve africa's unique nature
and it's homegrown you have all the
resources
africa has an abundance of wind and sun
what is needed is investment and with
global gateway we aim to provide access
to electricity from renewable sources
to 100 million people by 2030
and with clean hydrogen
africa can both power its rising
industry
and sell even clean energy to other
continents
we are already working intensively with
namibia on this
and this is a true win-win situation
it is good for all our economies
and it is good for our planet
and finally
global gateway is about cooperation with
neighbors and like-minded partners
we european have learned
that economic integration
is the best antidote against war
but in many parts of the world
it is easier to trade with far away
economic giants
than with the country next door
so global gateway will invest in
strategic transport corridors
with a focus on clean modes of transport
for instance to link land lock areas
with seaports
we are already at work with our partners
to identify and develop these corridors
for instance in the western balkans
or for example in africa and in central
asia
and this will then create new trade
opportunities but also better neighborly
relations
likewise
global gateway is open for cooperation
with any country
that shares our goals
like our friends for example in the
united states in japan and india
with global gateway
we are showing the power
of a value-driven investment agenda
democracies are putting citizens
and local communities
and the future of our planet
at the core of our action
and during the pandemic we have seen
that others promised a lot but in the
end it were the democracies
who delivered
so let us work for sustainable mutual
benefit
this is the philosophy of global gateway
it can help to bridge across the world's
investment gap
but it is much much more
it is an opportunity to end unhealthy
dependencies
and to invest in partnerships of equals
instead
global gateway is the future of our
development cooperation
and i'm grateful to all of you who have
joined us today to shape this future
together i will be very keen to learn
about the progress
of concrete projects
and i thank you and welcome you to the
european development days
many thanks for having me
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much president vandalian
for indeed helping us set the scene of
this global gateway now ladies and
gentlemen to continue our opening
ceremony it is my great honor to welcome
her majesty the queen of the belgians
and unsdg advocate your majesty please
[Music]
your excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
it is a great pleasure to be able to
participate in person again
in this multi-partner international
conversation
under the auspices of the european
development days
speaking as an advocate for the un's
sustainable development goals
my main task today
is to remind all stakeholders of the
importance of this global agenda
unanimously adopted by the international
community
in 2015
its purpose is to make the world more
equitable
and more sustainable for all by 2030
unfortunately
these priorities have been hijacked
by two major crisis
the covet pandemic
and the resurgence of war in europe
the consequences
in terms of human suffering
for the economy worldwide
and for the food security of many
countries are dramatic
these emergency situations
have compelled decision makers to focus
mainly
on managing the short term
human and financial resources have been
diverted to respond to immediate needs
however
this should not become the new normal
let us not forget that
beyond statistics on goals and targets
the sdgs outline a shared vision and
provide a world map for the future we
want to achieve
we must consider how even in times of
emergency
decision makers organizations and
individuals
can re-establish and continue to expand
their capacity
including their capacity to plan for a
more distant future
they must be able to implement those
plans as well
devising local
national
and international policies and
cooperation systems
to reach the objectives
that the international community
has set for itself
so that the vision can be made reality
developing and prioritizing policies and
actions
to combat climate change
poverty
gender inequality
pollution
and the depletion of world resources
is a first step
the european green deal
is a bold project
and illustrated
that it can be done
implementation will often require
leaving the beaten path
thinking and acting differently
changing mindsets
collectively shaping new priorities and
new forms of collaboration that produce
win-win results
on the basis of shared values
we know
that innovative solutions can come from
the entire world
from researchers business
ordinary citizens
and young people
they might address local problems and
use local resources
but they can still inspire others
even in far away settings and different
environments
the impressive set of connections
proposed by the global gateway strategy
will hopefully become
a network of two-way streets and avenues
which will help ideas
and experiences
flow in many directions and enrich one
another
excellence
madame
ladinite the shack person
is
mercy
[Applause]
thank you very much your majesty
ladies and gentlemen please now welcome
on stage with us his majesty king let's
see the third king of lizotto
[Music]
[Music]
your majesty
queen of the belgians
your excellencies
heads of state and government here
present
the president of the european council
his excellency mr shah michelle
the president of the european commission
her excellency ms essila vanderlian
distinguished guests
ladies and gentlemen
it is indeed a great pleasure and honor
to address you today
at this opening ceremony of the 15th
edition
of the european development days
i am grateful
for the gracious invitation
that has been extended to the kingdom of
lesotho
to take part
in this important forum
which brings together
a variety of participants
to share knowledge
experiences and
ideas that can assist our efforts
of finding solutions
to the world's most
critical challenges
the theme of this year
reads global gateway
building sustainable partnerships
for a connected world
i believe
that this theme is highly relevant and
appropriate
in view of the political
economic and social challenges
we have had to grapple with
in recent years
the kovit 19
pandemic has laid bare
the existing inequalities
within our countries
and the inequalities
between the countries of the north
and those of the south
and it has forced us
to recognize
that stronger partnerships
cooperation and collaboration
are essential elements
in dealing with and confronting
global crises
now
and in the future
the kingdom of lesotho
has enjoyed and benefited
from a strong partnership
with the eu
spanning a period of almost 50 years
this partnership has been characterized
by a cooperation in many areas that we
regard
as critical pillars
for our economic advancement
and political
stability
the eu has provided valuable assistance
and support
to our efforts of strengthening
democratic institutions
and entrenching democratic culture
recently the eu has provided
much needed support
to our judiciary
in dealing with sensitive high-profile
cases
that are now before the court of law
i cannot fail to mention
the significant contribution that the eu
has made
towards our national reforms process
this important and historical national
exercise
encompassing
constitutional
parliamentary
judiciary
security public service
media and economic reforms
is expected
to lay solid foundations
for improved governance
political stability
greater national cohesion
and enduring peace
in a few months
the kingdom will hold a general election
and once again we're looking forward
to hosting the eu observer mission
which will observe and ensure
that this important democratic
exercise
will meet all the required standards and
principles
of a free and fair election
your excellencies distinguish ladies and
gentlemen
i am certain that you will agree with me
that climate change
poses an existential threat
to our world
and to humanity at large
it is a known fact
that climate change
threatens people and countries
in all corners of the world
with food and water scarcity
increased flooding
extreme heat severe droughts
increased levels of disease
and devastating
economic loss
the government and people of lesotho
would therefore
like to applaud and command
the european union
for conceiving this noble gateway
strategy
this noble global gateway strategy
that aims to
among many other things
develop sustainable responses and
solutions
to the problem
of climate change
in recent years
the eu has proved to be
one of lesotho's strongest partners in
our fight
to mitigate the harshest if the harshest
effects
of climate change
it has provided and continues to provide
the government of lesotho
with technical support and assistance
to institute appropriate policies
that will help to reverse
environmental degradation
and enable a more efficient adaptation
to climate change
having recognized that one of our
countries biggest asset
is water
and that this valuable asset
could be a key determinant
to develop to to the development and
growth
of a green and resilient economy
the eu is also supporting the government
and people of lesotho
in our efforts to increase
availability of clean and
affordable water and sanitation systems
and is supporting
initiatives
that increase our capacity and ability
to manage our water resource
in an integrated and sustainable manner
so that this valuable asset
can yield greater benefits
for both people
and
nature excellencies distinguished ladies
and gentlemen
it is my sincerest hope
that the discussions deliberations
and exchanges that will take place
during the course of this forum
will bring us closer
to forging genuinely sustainable
partnerships
today's pressing and sometimes daunting
challenges
such as climate change conflicts
and pandemics
can only be overcome
if we all act
in a spirit of collaboration
and cooperation
within a connected global community
let me conclude my remarks
by wishing this 15th edition of european
development days
much success
and may we all leave here inspired
to build new and strong partnerships
for inclusive prosperity
and enduring peace
i thank you all for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much your majesty
now ladies and gentlemen i would like to
invite to join me here on stage mr
charles michelle president of the
european council
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ukrainian
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
prosperity
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much mr president
i would like now to invite
mr nana akufo ado president of the
republic of ghana to the stage please
[Music]
your majesties
your excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
i thank the president of the european
commission
excellency frau urslav on the lion
for the invitation to be part of this
year's european development days
it has been two years of virtual
meetings
since the outbreak of coffee 19
so it feels good to be able to meet
again
in person
to chart a sustainable course for our
collective future
particularly that of europe and africa
although the initial response was
somewhat flawed
the level of global cooperation
witnessed in the fight against the
ravages of covet 19
demonstrates the importance of
multinationalism
as a progressive tool
to finding solutions to the plethora of
global issues
the theme chosen for this year's event
global gateway
building sustainable partnership for a
connected world is thus happily apt in
view of the times
excellencies
global efforts to help countries correct
the devastation caused by the pandemic
and also achieve the un-2030 sustainable
development goals
are coming up short
finance and investment needs of
developing countries have increased
as carbon 19 has not only reversed years
of progress
but also also reveal critical gaps in
infrastructure in areas such as
healthcare and digital connectivity
sadly
the prospects for us in the developing
world
making up lost ground
through inclusive and sustainable
recovery efforts have been further
severely undermined
in recent months
by the consequences of the russian
invasion of ukraine
which are having a negative impact on
commodity and fuel prices
stoking a food crisis
and provoking financial market
volatility
though the bombs might be dropping on
cities half a world away
they're hitting our pockets not only in
ghana and in africa but also in much of
the developing world
indeed
a recent united nations report
estimates that 70 percent of africa's
economies are at severe risk
from the russian war in ukraine
the world bank tells us
the subsequent of the conflict
the number of poor people in sub-saharan
africa
would rise
from
413 million
to
463 million this year an increase of 50
million persons
in the midst of this
18 african economies
have experienced credit downgrades
even when all economies are suffering
adverse fallout from last year's
pandemic
and we in africa
are also facing the risk of the
so-called tabor tantrums as investors
exit our markets
thereby exacerbating the increasing cost
of borrowing
at this moment
support for non-imf program countries
to alleviate the dead burden is limited
the initial facility
designed by the g20 countries to offer
respite to economies with elevated debt
challenges
the debt service suspension initiative
dssi
has expired since december
2021 and has not been renewed
beyond the dssi
the g20 common framework
promised a comprehensive solution to the
debt issue
to date
the few countries that took on the
associated risk by applying have yet to
receive the much needed relief
in these trying times
the amount of 650 billion
united states
special
dollar special drawing rights
approved for the imf in august 2021
was meant to provide significant relief
however
based on allocation principles
economies in africa got a total of only
33 billion
united states dollars about 5 percent
moreover the promise to reallocate
some 100 billion united states dollars
of the sdr allocations to african
economies
agreed to at the paris summit in may
2029
2019
has so far yielded about 36 billion
united states dollars in pledges as of
april 2022
then there is the matter of the african
risk premium
when african entities are borrowing from
the market
which increases the cost of capital
and which must be addressed
especially as africa provides the
highest return
on investments obtainable anywhere
and has a good record of debt repayment
likewise
we must deal together with tax dodging
and illegitimate commercial transactions
by con multinationals
which account for 60 percent
of the annual 88 billion united states
dollars of illicit financial flows from
the african continent
in this regard
the recent pledge from the g7 countries
to exact a new global minimum tax rate
of 15 percent on multinationals
regardless of where they are based
is a step in the right direction
even if the rate is low
the combined effects
of debt situation
rising interest rates and rising cost of
living
are resulting in severe macroeconomic
and financial instability
what is clear
is that the ensuing damage
cannot be cured so easily with the
limited fiscal tools at our disposal and
national policy adjustments
excellencies
the long-standing relationship
between africa and europe
founded on ties of blood
culture
geography and history
should serve as a platform
for enhanced cooperation
between us
indeed
no one needs to tell us
that the issues of peace
progress and sec prosperity in africa
and europe are deeply intertwined
which presuppose that ensuring the
development of africa
should be in our common interest
now more than ever
strong partnership between europe and
africa
reinforced political dialogue
and expanded cooperation in the fields
of economic growth and international
security are required
we have to work together
to achieve our goals
including a fair
equitable process of energy transition
which recognizes that the entire african
continent
is responsible for less than four
percent of global admissions
and which safeguards the prospects of
africa's development
it is for these reasons
that the establishment of the 300
billion euro global gateway package
by the european union
which aims to boost public and private
investment
in the areas of infrastructure
energy
and green trans
transition
digital transformation
growth and jobs
transport and human development over the
next seven years is very much
welcomed this package
must be innovative in its approaches
to infrastructure investments and
financing
and should be characterized by demand
different projects which devel deliver
on african defined priorities
i'm hopeful
that over these two days
the series of high-level
panel sessions and debates
framed around the five key investment
areas of global gateway that is digital
climate and energy
transport
health education and research
will produce outcomes
that will prove beneficial
in the successful implementation of
infrastructural developments across
africa
in the next few years we must be able to
see tangible projects across africa as
proof
of the fruits of the strategic
partnership that exists between europe
and africa
excellent relations
between europe and africa are essential
to global security in this 21st century
which should lead us onto the path of
shared progress and prosperity the
excellence is i thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
thank you mr president thank you very
much
ladies and gentlemen now please welcome
mr mohammed ul ghazwani president of the
islamic republic of mauritania
[Music]
european
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
program
[Music]
[Music]
de la sante
the education
enforcement resilience economic social
through the global gateway
in opportunity the premier order
everywhere
excellent
freer
ensures
alternative energy proper constituting
important opportunity the cooperation of
europe
reinforces the advantage part of
proximity geographic
industry
[Music]
poverty
ladies and gentlemen i would
i'm getting out of the way while we are
cleaning up our stand ladies and
gentlemen i would like now to invite uh
to join us here on stage mr jose maria
nevis president of the republic of cabo
verde
[Music]
so
initiative
is
us
[Music]
inclusiveness
thank you very much mr president
ladies and gentlemen i now would like to
give the floor to ms sarah congo galwa
amadila who's the prime minister of the
republic of namibia
[Music]
thank you very much director of
proceedings
your
majesties
your excellencies
prime ministers ladies and gentlemen
namibia is pleased to participate in the
15th edition of the eu development days
that seeks to strengthen partnerships at
the international level for mutual
benefits as expressed through this
year's theme
global gateway the eu strategy to build
sustainable and resilient connections in
the world
i thank the eu commission for the
welcome and catechist extended to me and
my delegation
since our arrival
your majesties your excellencies
this edition of the eu development days
comes after the sixth european union
africa union summit that was held in
february this year where the heads of
states and government met to agree on a
joint vision for our two unions in a
renewed partnership
this renewed partnership addresses both
the immediate opportunities and
challenges we face
as well as the long-term possibilities
offered by our partnership
one of the significant outcomes of that
summit is the global gateway africa
europe investment package
which is part of the global gateway
strategy
with
150 billion euro investments
by 2027.
this platform in the next two days
affords us an opportunity to continue
our dialogue on this package by seeking
greater and deeper understanding on the
package and to develop approaches and
come up with solutions that would ensure
that the package helped build more
diversified
inclusive sustainable and resilient
economies that are also human centered
in its approach
it is important that whatever we do due
consideration is given to the priorities
and needs of african countries as well
we welcome the core aims of the package
which is to boost public and private
investment that builds on existing
initiatives and partnerships
particular areas of interest to many of
our countries would be investment in
energy including renewable hydrogen and
digital infrastructure
we recognize the impact of climate
change on our countries and economies
and the need for a transition to
sustainable sources of energy
as provided for in the outcome of the
summit we wish to reiterate the need for
energy transition that is fair
just and equitable taking into account
specific and diverse orientations of our
countries with regards to access to
electricity
covered 19 has had a devastating impact
on the global economy
in wild nation states were on a path of
recovery following two years of the
worst global pandemic in recent history
oil and food prices were on the upward
trend since the beginning of 2022
moreover droughts heat waves floods and
other climatic conditions have ravaged
countries over the last few years
further affecting the economic stability
and recovery of nations
it is within this context that less than
a month ago his excellency dr hager
gottfried gengob president of the
republic of namibia participated in the
world economic forum in davos
switzerland where he showcased namibia's
innovative approach to kick-start
namibia's economic recovery by using its
renewable energy potential to contribute
to a global just energy transition
namibia has set an ambitious goal to
reduce carbon emissions by 91 percent by
2030.
in this regard investment in the green
hydrogen economy is an imperative if we
are going to achieve this ambition
infrastructure is a key enabler in
unlocking development and in particular
the development of namibia's green
hydrogen industry
the southern corridor development
initiative which is a key output under
our national development plans consists
of a portfolio of complementary projects
and infrastructure
in the southern region of namibia
it maximizes the opportunity presented
by green hydrogen and ammonia for the
country
preliminary market estimate indicates
that the keras region in southern
namibia stands to absorb potential
foreign direct investment of 6 billion
us dollars produce 2 million tons of
green ammonia
generate in excess of 800 million
dollars in revenue per annum in house
generation assets of 5 gigawatts with
the capability to produce power at less
than 2
u.s cents per kilowatts
namibia has already signed several
memoranda of understanding with some of
our european partners being germany
netherlands and belgium for the
production and distribution of green
hydrogen to be produced at the coast of
namibia with solar and wind renewable
energy sources
we are engaging in a similar dialogue
with the european union
namibia sports authority has set aside
350 hectares of land at the port of
wolfish bay for the allocation of green
hydrogen related industries
furthermore a preliminary analysis by
the world bank of the green hydrogen
market and levelized cost of hydrogen
shows namibia could produce highly
competitive green ammonia
however with little national demand
exports will be key to our green
hydrogen strategy
the global ammonia market today is 180
million metric tons driven by
fertilizers and mining explosives
production
the global market is expected to grow to
over 500 million metric tons by 2050
driven by marine shipping and power
systems aimed at decarbonization
especially by major developed economies
with net zero policies by 2050
your majesties your excellencies prime
ministers
namibia's vast potential to generate
renewable energy utilizing existing
infrastructure and with investments in
new infrastructure is driving the
diversification of our economy
the green hydrogen proposition will make
it one of the most competitive countries
in the world to produce renewable
hydrogen as we seek to continue on our
developmental path we are improving our
policy environment for investment
including undertaking the necessary
policy reforms that would make it easier
to invest we are a politically stable
country with the necessary systems in
place to do business
we are committed to transparency and
work tirelessly to promote our country
as a viable investment destination by
offering opportunities for investment
through public-private partnership and
foreign direct investment
in this statement i highlighted a number
of issues that are important for our
country such as the impact of covet 19
human development economic
recovery in a post-covered world and
sustainable energy production
and transition we are hopeful that the
africa europe investment package with
due consideration to the priorities and
needs of countries such as ours on the
african continent will support our
developmental ambitions as we seek to
industrialize i thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much madame prime
minister
ladies and gentlemen i have now the
pleasure of welcoming mr john briseno
prime minister of belize
[Music]
our majesty queen
of belgium
president of the european commission
colleague heads of state
and government
distinguished representatives
ladies and gentlemen
we meet in beautiful brussels
at a decisive
moment
not only is the world in the recovery
stages of the global pandemic
but we are also witnessing a
catastrophic
invasion by russia
of ukraine
whose impact has spread far beyond
their borders
indeed far beyond
this continent
today
our small nations in the caribbean
including belize
are grappling
with high inflation rates
on sustainable debt
increasing poverty
food and energy in security
and climate change
among other major external factors
hindering the development of our nations
for example
in belize
when my administration took office in
november 2020
belize's debt
to gdp ratio
stood at an alarming 133
unemployment
stood
at 30
and the poverty rate was estimated at
about 60 percent
immediately my government proceeded with
a multi-year recovery and
transformational
framework
called plan belize
this set the foundation for our
medium-term development
strategy
which allowed us
to re-establish
macroeconomic order
and stimulate investments in several key
sectors
over the next five years
plan belize has already
started to bear
good fruit
last november
we successfully converted
an unsustainable private debt
by paying it off
and converting it into a blue bond
that will assist us with our marine
conservation efforts
while helping us to achieve
that sustainability
this transaction alone decreased debt to
gdp by an estimated 12 percent
set aside almost four million dollars
annually for marine conservation and set
up a marine conservation trust fund
that will be worth almost
100 million dollars by 2040.
belize like other caribbean nations will
continue to value relationships with our
development partners like the european
union and its member states who have
been some of our closest and most
committed partners
historically
we have used eu funds to improve the
livelihoods of the belgian people
through three main
instruments
the european development fund
accompanying measures for sugar
and the accompanying measures for
bananas
now we are turning a new page in the
development partnership under the eu's
ndic
global europe instrument
the eu's contribution has helped with
meaningful rural transformation through
the development of small and micro
enterprise infrastructure
through major investments that have
driven our competitiveness on
international markets and in renewab in
areas of renewable energy
all initiatives that are helping us
improve productivity and reducing
poverty
across
the caribbean commitments
by the eu have assisted our governments
with green growth and sustainable social
economic development along with our
efforts to enhance good governance and
improve
regional integration
allow me
a minute
to express on behalf of the people of
belize and our neighbor guatemala our
sincere appreciation to the eu
for its efforts at regional peace and
security
your commitment to the culture of peace
program and in our efforts to find a
peaceful and lasting resolution of the
guatemalans unfounded territorial claim
to belize territory is invaluable and
continues to be
important
like you
we desire to live in peace
for this reason we strongly commend
condemn what is currently occurring in
the european we applaud measures by the
eu
to bolster their support for the
european people
excellencies
belize like the rest of the caribbean is
working towards meaningful sustainable
development
and the economic transformation of our
people
to this end
we will continue mobilizing resources
and expertise that will help with the
advancement of our people we look
forward to the support and engagement of
our eu counterparts especially as we
seek to address global inflation
food security and
energy security
but any talk of the future would be
deficient without addressing the very
real trip that persists at this very
moment
to truly embody the forum's global
gateway strategy we need to address
global inflation and condemned
the globally geopolitical tensions that
threaten to diminish
global connectivity and the investments
we have made in driving innovation
as we come together
at this
15th european development days forum
let us ensure
that our dialogue is fruitful
our outcomes effective
and our alliances enduring
the people we represent
and the global community of which we are
all a part of
are counting on us to turn our words
into action thank you very much
thank you very much mr prime minister
and i would like to invite mr anatole
coline makuso prime minister of the
republic of congo
[Music]
you
economic special
the convergence objective entrepreneur
plan of the development
[Music]
actually
southern conflictual
journalist instructor
for construction me
and kotakot
concentrate
journalist and promoter
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen i would now like to
invite you to welcome mr aziz akanush
head of government of the kingdom of
morocco
[Music]
[Music]
oh
and connectivity
africa
mercy
ladies and gentlemen i would like now to
invite on stage mr werner hoyer the
president of the european investment
bank
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much and sorry for this
theatrical
input
at least i got your attention now
majesties
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
it's a privilege
joy and honor for me to be with you
last year
i met
many of the leaders that are here today
with us
still
with a lot of caution
and distancing
but one sensed optimism
and the feeling that the panemic should
be mitigated
maybe one day defeated
and some normality would return
none of us thought
that russia was planning a war
with global consequences
we were quite rightly focused on
addressing the fallout of the pandemic
and the twin challenges of the green
and digital transition
and crucially
how we could turn these challenges
into opportunities
the world has changed since president
obama
first announced global gateway
as a new strategic priority for the
european union
and the change
was unfortunately not for the better
the relevance of the global gateway
initiative
has only increased as we need to enhance
connections with our partners
those represented here today
and many others around the world
deal with the challenges of food and
energy security
double down on sustainable development
goals in the face of an alarming
trajectory
and protect
the global vulnerable from the
devastating consequences
of climate change
covet
and now
war the interventions from all sides so
far have stressed
the urgent need to accelerate
transformational investment
at the same time to find adequate models
to finance it
and there it is crucial
that we do not believe
that the solution can come exclusively
from taxpayers money
we need to mobilize the private sector
to take considerable part of the tab
the time is now
the conversations at edds
lead to leaders to tangible outcomes
reflecting common priorities in a true
partnership
based on mutual interest
at eib the eubank we stand ready to
deliver concrete
investment based solutions
for the challenges we are facing
my sense is
that the war in ukraine is the strongest
possible argument
to green our economies and to accelerate
our independence
from fossil fuels
this decade remains critical to address
our planet's climate emergency to
achieve this
trillions of investments are required
and it is clear
that the
issue cannot be solved by a single actor
alone
last year at eib we dedicated more than
one third of our landing outside the
european union to climate action in
africa for example together with our
partners
we are supporting solar energy in zambia
wind power and geothermal projects in
kenya hydropower in liberia ghana
and madasca madagascar and off-grid
solutions that will improve access to
energy for household and micro
entrepreneurs
we need to continue on this path and
multiply
our efforts
as
erb we stand ready to deliver concrete
investment based solutions for the
challenges we are facing
now we are
realizing
what kind of
unexpected success has been exceeded
when we were overwhelmed by the covet
crisis just two years ago
and every scientist in the world would
tell us well one day you need not only
medication and diagnostics you will need
vaccination against this disease but
vaccinate vaccine development takes five
to ten years
well
only a few months later
we are supporting the deployment of mrna
technology in developing countries
to face covet and many other diseases
we need the same
determination again
the case of hydrogen
the case of digitalization
take the case of education and skills
and opportunities for women
this goes to the very heart
of what the eu bank is doing
as an engineering driven bank
infrastructure projects have
traditionally played an important part
of what we do
and when it comes to energy
we are at the forefront of promoting new
sustainable energy solutions globally
we are also the ifi with the largest
exposure in the digital economy sector
current portfolio accounts to 1 11.5
billion euros
and with our newly established
financial armed specialized arm for
international partnerships erb global
we now intend to take these areas to the
next level and closer to our global
partners
as the european commission's key partner
in developing in delivering global
gateways we will step up
team europe investments around the world
let's work together
on these ambitious
aims
thank you very much for your attention
thank you very much mr hoyer
ladies and gentlemen i would now like to
welcome on stage ms odile reno basu
president of the european bank for
reconstruction
and development
that is making an entrance definitely
[Music]
your majesties
excellencies ladies and gentlemen dear
friends
i'm very happy to be here with you today
to discuss global gateway because
connectivity
is vital for development and for
economic resilience
this is why we at the ebrd
warmly welcome the eu's global gateway
strategy
our strategic priorities green equal and
digital
are totally aligned
and we are a natural partner for this
initiative
we strongly support the eu's guiding
principles for investment including
providing sustainable quality
infrastructure
that promotes high social and
environmental standards and equal
partnership
and leveraging the private sector
not only ebrd is part of the european
development landscape and team europe
but developing that the private sector
is in our dna
as this was very much said this morning
we are in extraordinary times
with the war on ukraine following the
covet pandemic
and this adds fresh urgency to the need
to connect better
the economic damage is severe both
inside ukraine
but also across other countries and
regions which face supply chain
disruption and worsening energy and food
security
with our strong presence in eastern
europe mediterranean countries caucasus
central asia
we can see firsthand the disruptions
generated by the war
and we are stepping up our support to
counterbalance these negative
impacts african and middle eastern
countries are particularly vulnerable to
the rising food and energy prices
and in our countries of operation in
north africa and the near east we are
scaling up our response by giving
priority to investments in agri-business
sector to help countries better manage
food security
and on energy security in line with the
eu's recent repower eu package we focus
on more energy efficiency
renewables and green hydrogen
and we are very proud to have 50 percent
of our overall investment last year in
the green sector
central asia is also directly impacted
by the war on ukraine
and there is an urgent need for reliable
alternative connections with the world
our study on sustainable transport
corridors connecting europe with central
asia conducted at the request of the
commission is a natural contribution to
the global gateway it will pave the way
for more transparent and sustainable
investment
opportunities so what can the ebrd bring
to the global gateway initiative
i think we can provide three four key
contributions the first one
is the fact that achieving integration
by improving connectivity is a core
element of our transition mandate we
have world experience in this space
always with an objective to quote in the
private sector link markets foster the
carbonization and achieve a just
transition
second our strengths lies in our ability
to work in both the private and the
public spheres
and to combine project work
project work with support for policy
reform
which has which has helping us
overcoming market barriers and
delivering more investments
one example i'm very proud of for for
example is the 6th of october dryport
project in egypt which refinance is the
first inland dry port in egypt it will
function as an extended gateway to the
deep seaports becoming an important
investment in green logistics and it's
the first public-private partnership in
egypt over a decade so big innovation
third
things we can bring cooperating with
other institutions which is vital
connectivity is an area where the ebrd
and european development finance
institution and the eib
we have jointly invested in the past and
will continue to explore opportunities
to enhance collaboration
and of course we have a long track
record of working with the commission
on transport on energy networks for
example in the western balkans or
promoting greener energy in central asia
and i would like to take this
opportunity to express our support for
this collaboration
fourth
digital is another ebrd strategic
priority and digital connectivity plays
a vital role in enabling the development
of the broader digital economy in our
countries of operation
let me just allow to say a few words on
ukraine because we are today there is
another event
tech for ukraine eu pledging event in
toulouse and to support development of
tech companies in ukraine
and more broadly on ukraine we are
working to provide urgent support to the
country and neighboring countries
to
face the impact of the war our objective
is to invest at least one billion this
year on areas such as energy security
food security vital infrastructure trade
finance support for pharmaceutical
companies
and there is a close link with the
connectivity agenda because our way
is to keep the real economy working
through finance that can helps keeping
the light on the trains running gas in
the eating system and food in the fields
and shops
and we will strongly support the
reconstruction of the country with a
priority to improve the interconnectness
of the ukrainian networks with the eu
our work in the last 30 years has taught
us lessons that can also apply to
designing and implementing the global
gateway and let me offer two key lessons
the first one is the importance of
flexibility providing a mix of
instruments guarantees but also
co-investment grants or grants for
technical assistance
to cover a wide range of needs and
situations
another lesson
is the importance of ownership by the
countries and partnership with
global community and the eu is very well
equipped to work with partners in the
country beneficiary countries and at the
global level with partners sharing its
vision
team europe is a very important tool for
this partnership and that's why we are
happy to participate to 25 team europe
initiative
of which 17 will support the global
gateway initiative in partner countries
looking forward
i would like to share our long-term
vision from an ibrd perspective to for
investing in sub-saharan africa too
our governors agreed last month on the
principle of limited and incremental
expansion into that region
and this will certainly when times come
open new opportunities for new
partnerships
for dbrd for now dbrd will continue
to invest
in changing lives across our region
and to work with our friends
in ukraine and beyond to promote
connectivity thank you very much
mr madame the president
ladies and gentlemen the time has come
to give the floor to the commission to
close the loop
and i therefore invite ms yuna
urpilainen european commissioner for
international partnerships
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for being here with us today
i think we have just
heard a number of inspiring remarks by
leaders from all around the world
leaders have really reminded us about
the importance
of achieving sustainable development
goals
they have also underlined
the need to work
in coordinated manner
to address the looming global food
crisis
and they have acknowledged
to the potential
of global gateway strategy in addressing
current global challenges
the european development days
are one of the largest
yearly events
organized by the european commission
i am delighted that we are once again
able to meet in person
we come together
to listen
to share
and to engage
this year
as you have heard
we have chosen to discuss global gateway
strategy
the eu strategy for building sustainable
links worldwide
in the next two days
around 100 events
will take place
they will allow us to go into the
details
of global gateway
we will definitely discuss geopolitics
how to finance this ambitious chart
strategy
and most importantly
hear from our partners
what global gateway means
for their regions and their citizens
it is very good program
and i wish you enjoy it
thank you very much for your
participation
thank you very much commissioner ladies
and gentlemen this concludes our opening
ceremony we will resume in this
particular studio at 12 25 with our next
session in the meantime the rest of the
program continues in parallel your
majesties your excellencies ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for being
with us this morning
[Music]